Maintenant qu'on a passé en revue tous les éléments du VQE, voyons
ce qu'on a appris et comment un ordinateur quantique l'exécute.
On commence avec notre état de référence soigneusement choisi, notre circuit paramétré,
un choix initial de paramètres et un Hamiltonien.
On passe tout ça à notre ordinateur quantique.
Avant que le Hamiltonien puisse être exécuté sur l'état ansatz,
on doit effectuer un pré-traitement classique du circuit
pour le rendre lisible par le matériel quantique, dans un processus appelé transpilation.
Il est aussi important de tirer le meilleur parti
de l'architecture des qubits dans le vrai matériel pour obtenir les meilleurs résultats.
Ces processus sont souvent pris en charge automatiquement, pour qu'on n'ait pas
à connaître explicitement la connectivité des qubits,
les fidélités des gates, et ainsi de suite.
La tâche consiste maintenant à mesurer l'état résultant
et à estimer la valeur d'expectation, qui sera ensuite
optimisée par un optimiseur classique.
Cette mesure est effectuée en faisant pivoter la base de mesure,
puis en combinant les résultats de mesure pour obtenir la valeur d'expectation.
Ce résultat paramétré est ensuite transmis
à l'optimiseur classique, qui trouve de nouveaux paramètres pour l'état.
Ensuite, le processus se répète.
Un pré-traitement classique crée un nouveau circuit paramétré
et on applique le même Hamiltonien qu'avant.
À noter que dans tout le processus VQE, on ne change que les états
via les paramètres, qui se rapprochent de plus en plus de l'état fondamental.
On répète ça jusqu'à être satisfait du résultat.
Et voilà.
Je m'appelle Victoria Lipinska et c'était le cours sur le variational quantum eigensolver.